this is incredible I literally not seen
a calculator I've not seen an actual
calculator in a long time
look at this rare I like the wrapping is
you're like I gonna sell this on eBay
[Music]
[Music]
the colleges fundamentally wish you
could take 40 years here's why your
parents here do you even care because
you can love to hear or your kissable
and out yet
your kids will not force their chips
you're the first generation your friends
are first generation that would really
struggle with leadership wide web to set
to reality looking gaming at scale like
everything under insurance is going to
be so so that might wait like
everything's in trouble yeah who is our
job we're like everybody looks to follow
on Twitter yeah
those watch the things you've done
legend last week yeah really all that
was fun yeah it's cool for you
especially right oh yeah
and real punch I'm glad you're here yeah
forget man talking hey Jim is applying
for selfie in that first video like did
you know simple love it I knew that it
was going to work but I never thought it
was going to lead to this and what I
mean by that is not I mean I probably
thought it was gonna be bigger I thought
I would be bigger it's not that I'm like
oh my god had this happened like I've
always kind of known you know even when
you're a kid you know your personality
if you pay attention you know your
personality type right like every time I
was in a new setting people reacted to
me in a big way
like infatuated I want to be your best
friend or like you I don't like that you
know like so I've always known I've got
a style that definitely like creates
energy especially like when I was 13 14
15 when everybody tries to be chill and
I was like too much and it was annoying
and it's an ADD so I always believed in
myself but you never know how it
manifests like if you told me what's
going to happen ten years I would tell
you that it's going to be way way WAY
big but I have no idea what I have no
idea other than as many people on earth
as I possibly can help it will know
about it and I'll enjoy doing it and
I'll be fully into it and I'm going to
try to break something that's the
establishment that's my truth I want to
break the establishment to the
establishment is vulnerable and I love
the competition of
[Music]
first of all 100 chairs can do it intro
let's do it I'm questions go cool so I'm
definitely excited to have Gary view
here for what is this
3434 that said I think a lot of people
speak the truth I think there's not a
lot of people who are hardcore hardcore
operators who speak the truth there's a
lot of voices out there who speaking the
truth they just don't have the
experience like I'm grossly underrated
because of my own narrative and the
meaning the way I narrate myself I'm a
doer like I'm in meetings like I just
walked from a company an office-wide
meeting in like m5 and the levites 7
meetings with employees like I'm doing
and I think you know I notice like I'm
not as sharp like for example I'm not
buying wine right now I can talk about
buying and selling product because I did
it every day of my life for 15 years am
i as sharp and talking about buying and
selling products as I was six years ago
no I'm not actively doing it and so I
think that one thing that everybody
who's listening should think about is
really audit who you're paying attention
to I don't you know I I think people
think I tell it like it is because I
curse and do it aggressively and I think
it gives a narrative of that but I think
a lot of people do that that are
completely full of [ __ ]
I think what is resonating with people
is I've got answers like the reason I do
Q&A all the time is because my only
answer because I'm doing it and I think
that's super interesting and I think
more of us Millennials in the workforce
so for one example I'm a huge millennial
advocate because I hate the narratives
that are painted on Millennials like I
know unlimited Millennials I want to
make lots of money work their asses off
right what I think Millennials so that's
where old people are wrong about
Millennials but where Millennials are
wrong as experience matters when I was a
millennial aka when I was in my 20s I
was ridiculously talented I went on to
become a very successful businessman I
was right about my bravado here's the
problem
41 year old Gary for Rash's 24 year old
Gary 17 years of experience is real so
old people me
year-olds and above need to stop talking
[ __ ] about Millennials but Millennials
need to start putting value on
experience because smartest Millennials
that are walking into my room telling me
how to run my business with zero context
of ever doing it is laughable at best
and obnoxious at worst patience
perseverance with you at and for
everybody even for 41 year olds right I
think I mean I live in patience I've got
everything in front of me I can cash it
in right now like I can I can take a
hundred million dollars off the table
right now and if you think about what
100 million dollars is right like what
fifty seven million dollars in post tax
money is that's generational wealth
right that is like I will never spend it
all
I'll probably just by investing it into
Facebook you know like like and then
Netflix and Amazon or the market taking
twenty five million dollars putting in
the market never thinking about again as
long as America doesn't melt I am like
I'll have a hundred million when I'm 70
like I'm set but I want to buy the New
York Jets I want to have an all-time
legacy so I practice patience patience
is mapping to your ambition if your
ambition is to live on you know thousand
dollars a year in Peru you know when you
can quit right now you don't need to be
patient like cash in catching all your
chips and mood right so I think I think
patience is a complete correlation to
your ambition I think the reason I am
Who I am is because I was born to be the
biggest showman [ __ ] a bullshitter
vault I'm born to be it and my father I
gave my mother so much credit my father
sucked it out of me at an early enough
stage that it became my truth and so I
have the pizzazz and ability to get you
but then I deliver on something more
noble than and that's why I think a lot
of people viscerally when they first see
me or like right because I have it and
then it takes time to be like oh wait a
minute right no this has been fantastic
thank you for coming down happy to have
you again you get awesome thanks
all right geez man thanks man appreciate
a pleasure thank you similar to the
interview
with the ambition podcast gives the
folks watching this for the maybe the
one person that hasn't heard your still
doesn't know your background do a little
bit of background before we jump in to
talk about sales marketing London before
I do that I'm always fascinated by
people's actions and how quickly you can
get insight the fact that you gave that
podcast a shout out in the intro to your
entire conference speaks obnoxious
volumes of how you think about the world
and like literally puts me in a really
good mood good for you and I'm probably
tremendous lesson you want talk about
alignment like doing right by the
universe doing the right thing is always
the right thing like genuinely it's not
a joke and I know I'm just very weird
start to a podcast or a conference it's
unbelievable to me how much more I want
to now give to you because of this
subtlest littlest thing you just did you
talked to us about how the Vayner
marketing team and the Vayner sales team
have collaborated to win those accounts
sales and marketing orbs are going to
hate each other because they have
different objectives and I am empathetic
to both let me explain salespeople I'm a
Salesman
salespeople one means that your
marketing team can do can change
everything for you they can go over 92
they could be the biggest Emile's you
can hate them and one activation at a
conference one video they make for
Facebook one thing one sponsorship one
thing six is everything they are
literally Mike Tyson right one punch and
that you have to respect there is
nothing you salesperson can do that will
ever map-21
excellent execution and marketing that
has the same impact next marketers
you're full of [ __ ] and you're fluffy
and most of the stuff you're going to do
doesn't matter
and you're highbrow and [ __ ] your
degrees and I don't give a [ __ ] what
Awards or what articles are written
about how clever you
you are not as practical you are not in
day to day you are you are the offensive
Superstar of a football team but
probably more like a wide receiver
because the CEO is the quarterback so I
love that that you can be highly
successful and I love that everybody
knows who you are but just like wide
receivers in the NFL you're a prima
donna
you're not practical you don't get the
full picture all the time and your sales
people aka the offensive line is there
day in and day out
rhyming trying to clean up for mistakes
you've made or misses you've had they
don't have the luxury of your budget
that has no quantifiable evidence
success and that you've got to be
empathetic to your sales team because
they are there and there is no wiggle
room your sales team can't say to the
CEO and more importantly the CFO well
the long-term impact of that
conversation I have will do this even
though it's true even though I am a
great salesperson because I set up sales
and I'll have a sales call that's
actually not even about the sales call
it's about what I'm going to try to do
with that person in a year but I'm only
justifying myself as a salesperson
wearing that Jersey you've got to make
sales and everybody's just looking at
your numbers nobody's giving you any
credit for the set up marketing person
you're only getting credit for the set
both of you need to desperately deploy
empathy to the other party and that's
the organizations that win but that's up
to the head of marketing and the head of
sales for her and him to be aligned at
the top and create the air cover for
those 83 employees or two employees to
be able to create that cohesive unit and
that's what great coaching is to get
your offensive and defensive coordinator
completely aligned to create a cohesive
unit and most people are not good at it
there you go
yes those are this Tupac or biggie
biggie bi gg I
it's my pleasure thanks guys that's
awesome great morning everybody up here
in Chattanooga Tennessee we're going to
go through a case study when I watch you
like this I think you can wear like this
started in my room everyone that didn't
like this one a lot what I'm hoping is
that inspires everybody to make scenes
from sitcoms to make documentaries to
make music videos to make things that
don't look like a commercial right I
mean I think I think when when you watch
the three of them the other two clearly
have commercial DNA whereas obviously
does not and I fundamentally pot
committed believe that that is the
creative that is going to work in a
shape I mean that's what people share
like people are going to share a
commercial there's not a single person
and so that's super important so no I
don't have
single day I would say I know you're
busy
we just wanna come in here but you're
already busy too awesome and real
pleasure yeah are you guys good man nice
to meet you I waved at your meeting I
didn't read it no worries no worries but
we were very thank you to have such a
real pleasure me rock earlier awesome
it's like a nice recess and rocky I made
him read all your books that we want to
daily be every single day yeah yeah
really yeah also thank you yeah
continued success here's our CEO right
he's in the closet that's good we're
gonna do it we ran out very executive
action that's right carry everything for
us but how are you hi let me have a Gary
time satin how are you you've got the
real spot yeah I've got a spot yeah I do
they hooked you a problem at they did
they take care of me fit me in here nice
some nice little view yeah this is what
you're like this is this is literally
literally how Wine Library was built
like by the way this exact table yeah
this exact same of Kostis yep and just
like in ER in like we built a closet
like a couple years earlier than that
toward me and my internet team set and
we the servers right in there like this
is incredible I literally not seen a
calculative but I've not seen an actual
calculator in a long time
look at this rare I don't think there
ever is you're like I going to sell this
on eBay
you know what's crazy about that spot
the third time this has happened that
I've looked at that spot and I always
think about Kennedy's assassination that
angle just something about like I'm like
there's a graph you know like there's a
belt like I don't know like just like
I'm in the South like I don't know like
it's just my head goes there every
single time
oh by the way when I was in Dallas one
time I had a little bit of time before
my airport the guys like you want to
drive the path I was like yeah it was
really quite nice talking just kind of
like I don't doubt that whole thing
really captivated me as a kid I would
think I'm like fit to like eleventh yeah
from six to eleven played every time
anything was about it I was like I was
so into it it captivated me we into the
conspiracy theories of it er oh for sure
that's like like a hundred something
happened something else like the force
will be with you always
today so foreign how to do the Tennessee
have some internal meaning some external
meetings that's it that's it I like this
character bubbles
yo Gary beard we got going on today not
much regular Gary
[Music]
if I could bless you with anything
besides health they would be
self-awareness like it is the ultimate
ultimate thing like if you actually know
who the [ __ ] you are [ __ ] gets weird if
you're really fully there and I mean
that like and somewhere I don't know if
it was circumstantial but the immigrant
thing or great parenting or mom and dad
had sex with the exact right moment and
gave me the right DNA something around
fourth grade I just everything became
very crystal clear which was oh [ __ ]
this system that I'm going through is
not for me how many rings Saturn has or
like you know you know any other
variable that I'm going to be taught
here and this is before I realized that
there were or anybody realized there
would be an internet that would
completely commoditize information right
this is not for me and so what was very
hard for me was when I was getting DS
and apps and my teachers and my friends
parents told me I was a loser that was
hard like you're still a kid as
confident as I was people looking you
dead in the face and saying you're not
going to mass to anything and really
meaning it is challenging or like
literally friends parents you could see
they were disappointed that their friend
was friends with me because they were
worried that I would rub off because
they're only KP I was go to Harvard
right so that was challenging but from
the day I was Rick right I would tell
you that when you were doing what you're
supposed to do I'm really you know I
don't listen I don't believe in like the
secret or like I'm not very like I don't
know how then doubt I am or not but I
would be lying to you and to you guys
like this is the only thing I want I do
the pain right like so what's hard
what's hard and a lot of you know this
is when there's nobody else to blame
it's your [ __ ] fault but I don't know
how to breathe in any other way I love
the fact that every single problem is
mine I love that I'm actually a
firefighter you know everyday it's bad
like I'm nervous this is real there is
an underlining nervousness running in
the background of me right now because I
know I'm going to be zoned into this and
when I'm done in 40 minutes I'm going to
take my phone out and it's highly likely
that there's some [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
right but that is all I know
that's all I've ever been that's all you
know like I've always wanted all the
responsibility having coach they're like
I want to take the last shot and if I
make it I want all the [ __ ] accolades
and if I miss it I want everybody to
[ __ ] on me and so it's not been hard
what's hard now is praying that the
people I love are healthy so that I
don't get derailed from doing what I
love to do like knowing that this is the
prime of my career and it's so awesome
and I can only hope for the kind of
health that has been like business is
not hard to me because it's what I do
best
everything else is hard to me like
hanging a [ __ ] picture to me is
extremely hard like ordering food doing
anything logistics oriented like if
you're told me to book my own flight
home today I [ __ ] crumble like a
cheap chair but like run a 500 million
dollar business like and deal with all
the pressures that's my natural state
were obsessed and I think that voice
saves time and time is the ultimate
arbitrage and that most of the things I
spend my time on right now it
brainstorming in my head are trying to
figure out how to be part of the morning
routine that I'm convinced is going to
be a I and voiced out that everybody's
going to wake up and say Alexa or Google
home or something else
give me my morning routine I believe
every one of us are going to listen to
information for the first 7 to 11
minutes of our morning while we brush
our teeth and I'm dying to figure out
how to be one of the voices of that me
as gary is like your daily business
motivation and then me as a client so
this is not a joke you're gonna love
this and I love you for asking this
I'm so pod committed I'm actually trying
to buy an umbrella company or invest in
one this is so weird
look about how I'm think about this I
want to buy or start an umbrella company
just so I can build an Alexis skill and
a Google home skill to be the brand that
provides you the weather every more like
I want to build the best weather app for
the voice world it's like owning the
first result on Google search for
weather that's just how I decided I
wanted to the point we don't that's my
personal like Oh wouldn't it be fun to
build like a four hundred million dollar
umbrella business on the back of our big
Alexa because like your your weather is
brought to you like Gumby umbrellas and
like people will hear that four hundred
trillion times they're like it's so fat
I'm a big believer I believe in it the
most awesome thanks guys I had to start
a city it helped hundreds millions of
people out of poverty how would I go
about it ah so what can we dig into it a
little bit so in the in the if I if I I
would think about it in two ways
short-term versus long-term so my
short-term answer is quite weird which
is I would probably fundraise against
the top point zero zero zero one percent
of human beings and try to take you know
the trillion errors are giving 99
percent of their wealth away I think
it's the altruistic type thing that you
could commence the buffets and the gates
and the characters of the world to give
you disproportionate capital that
basically big the financial elements
that you would need for those people and
then bring them into that environment
and then give them half and then make
them earn half and create some sort of
machine right that would be what I would
do if I had to do it in a 10-year window
at a much greater level I would try to
create the most capitalistic environment
that falls like I always think I think
things that are so challenging come in
pulling from opposites I think America
has such strength right I would I don't
it's such a complicated question so I
can't answer it very quickly but
whatever would look like it would look
like pulling from opposite direction
meaning how do you build a city that
rewards meritocracy but takes care of
the people that naturally don't have the
DNA disposition and I think that tension
in the US has been very successful for
three hundred years and I think
replicating that with with all the
learnings that's going to work in the
u.s. system maybe like the birth child
of like eighty percent us ten percent
Sweden 10-person China or maybe 70
percent us actually 70 percent us 15
Sweden 15 China feels like the right
place for me
like does every caste
Carolina kick I came to hit a coffee
they never would have known that kid
head Bob looking on and on never gonna
give up on the game I generals you hard
to say when you open it I got the game
in a hole over there like a pea when I
fumble and these other rappers be
malfunctioning and Maegan Woodin okay so
listen I mean I'll be available for the
call whenever we can all get on but the
answer is a the answer is this that's
what you need to go
I'm not going to chill we we have the
right team my internal team we're not
going to like if you spend a dollar will
spend it the best way possible against
the reality of your business and the
reality of the Facebook and influencers
marketplace so I feel very confident on
the limit coming to tell and they press
up and telling no one up again and again
you played my pen game crazy I'm still
in the game like maybe a woman I'd a
Mercedes but I'm gonna come and it's
gonna be rainy better with a windows got
the dead prez ragin like if 1980
yo man scared be what up my man life
good Atlas I'm running this meeting but
I had like one second I'm just so fired
up that you had context for me and what
I'm up to like let's stay in real touch
man you're like literally on my list of
like I made a list of nine guys but I
think people are sleeping on and have it
and like not you listen they're not
sleeping on your you're on the radar but
I have a funny feeling about you my man
gonna come in no rant I don't know did I
come in I come in and taking the crown
up into when the ground like it's a
friend nice is that right yeah I just
know what well I did I didn't see you
two you're on your way up Oh got it got
it
too many people always want to justify
their short-term behavior for having
some big macro vision like opportunity
comes like when you're right and sort of
like being right about social media made
me famous let alone gave me business
opportunities I wasn't sitting around
six years ago being like rappers and
athletes are going to be want to be my
friend because of this you can't even
think that way you just know that it's
right and you build on it eSports is
right period and the period
I've been learning the game in a break
in a poem I've been doing it's my whole
life I've been falling down
and I know because I'm ready to go guys
quick fun back actually I want you to do
this go to Oprah's Instagram account
right now and go all the way down and
look at her first Instagram photo ever
I'm serious do it right now while
Megan's talking I literally went into a
hotel room and I was like Oprah listen
to me you bit my mom loves a certain
Oprah you have to be on the Instagram
I'm like you have to be on his rip she's
like what do I take a picture of them
like me the fact the fact that Matt is
still there i screen shoot it like every
six months because every like I always
think like eventually she's going to
just delete it I believe that voice in
the morning the first three to ten
minutes is kind of like the new be the
first result on a Google search for the
next half decade and I think everybody
here who's doing marketing whether you
run a brand whether you started a fund
and you want to be in that world
penetrating people's first ten minutes
that they listen to I think it's going
to be big sakes big money I believe
history just repeats itself if you look
at the behavior of when the alarm clock
radio came out of how many of tens of
millions of Americans had their alarm go
off and give them the morning radio show
or the more like 1010 wins in New York
like giving them the first kind of eight
to ten minutes as they got ready ready
such an opportunity if you're willing to
build a custom skill and put your brand
on it levar burton was the first
celebrity on twitter for real for real
for real like before anybody came before
Ashton's competition with CNN to get to
a million before MC Hammer who was early
before Chamillionaire who's early
chameleon or was early LaBarbara and was
like yo I'm here and everybody followed
my whole life I've been fighting that my
whole
and I know the time cuz I'm ready to go
ready to go ready to go
ready to go longer my friends have been
telling me bro how much you blow I know
why'd you show up the show that go to go
on the look I got and Nas being fake
with me thinking about the money that
could take from me I'm gonna make it on
my own
wait and see they y'all gonna wish they
invented in